L'été touche à sa fin. Ah je sais, ça fait pas plaisir, mais c'est comme ça. Toujours est-il que c'est le moment
idéal pour flâner au soleil, cueillir quelques mûres, se bâfrer, avoir les doigts violet. Remarquez, c'est un peu
énervant les taches de mûres hm, et pourtant il y a pire, vraiment, vraiment pire.
* Musique de générique *
Tout l'été, DTC vous aide à éviter les pièges et les
dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et votre santé.
* Musique de générique *
DTC, partenaire de votre été.
Si je vous dis ténia, vous me dîtes "Ah oui, le ver solitaire".
(Romain)  - Ah oui, le ver solitaire !
- Voilà. Si je vous dis ténia du renard, vous me dîtes "Hm, je m'en fou je ne suis pas un renard"
(Romain) - Hm, je m'en fou je ne suis pas un renard !
- Oui, voilà, c'est bon.
Et surtout, vous me dîtes "Attends, mais quel rapport avec les m.."
(Romain) - Attends, mais quel rapport avec les m..
- Oh, tu arrêtes maintenant, tu vas arrêter un p'tit peu !
* bip *
* Générique *
- Ah, putain, bon on en était où ?
* bip *
Alors, le rapport entre le ténia, le renard, les mûres et vous, j'avoue c'est pas... bon, je vais vous expliquer
Le ténia du renard c'est quoi ?
Le ténia du renard c'est une maladie dont le nom
scientifique est l'échinococcose alvéolaire. Elle est causée par un parasite qui s'appelle
l'échinococcus multilocularis et qui n'hésite pas à élire domicile dans l'intestin des renards.
C'est spécial hein, moi je préfère quand c'est un peu plus lumineux, mais bon, on est pas chez Stéphane Plaza.
L'autre particularité de l'échinococcus multilocularis, c'est de pondre une quantité d'oeufs assez faramineuse
qu'on retrouve ensuite dans le caca des renards.
Vous commencez à voir venir non ?
Et oui, pour peu qu'un renard un tant soit peu chenapan voire sacripouille, enfin, un sacré vaurien quoi
Pour peu qu'un renard donc, ai été pris d'une violente envie de déféquer en passant devant le
bosquet de mûriers que vous vous apprêtez à dévaliser, vous avez un risque de vous retrouver en train de
bouloter des baies pleines d'échinococcus multilocularis. Alors, vous me direz, so what?
Et alors ?
(Romain) - * rire *
- Non, non,..
Et alors, le problème, c'est que ces oeufs ne vous étaient pas destinés. Normalement, c'est des petits rongeurs
qui auraient dû les manger. Et les oeufs auraient pu gentiment se développer, bien au chaud dans leur foie
devenir des larves, attendre qu'un renard mange le rongeur en question et élire domicile dans l'intestin
du renard et y pondre leurs oeufs.
Mais du coup là c'est vous qui avez mangé les oeufs. Donc, les larves elles vont se développer dans votre foie.
Mais vous n'allez sûrement pas vous faire manger par un renard. Donc les larves elles vont continuer à grandir,
elles vont peut-être envahir vos poumons, votre cerveau, d'autres organes autour, en suite, il va rien se passer
pendant cinq, peut-être quinze ans et puis les premiers signes vont apparaître.
Mal au ventre, perte de poids, fatigue, des signes que.. ça va pas très fort au niveau du foie, le problème c'est
qu'à ce stade, les dégâts sont déjà bien lourds et que si on fait rien, benh on meurt, pour une mûre au caca de renard
Comment éviter de choper le ténia du renard ? Alors, oui, du coup, j'imagine que maintenant vous allez hésiter à
manger des mûres ou tout autre type de baie d'ailleurs. Écoutez, ce serait dommage, d'abord parce que bon,
benh, c'est hyper bon et ensuite, parce que, bonne nouvelle, c'est une maladie rare, très rare.
On parle de dix à quinze cas par an en France et en plus, des renards infectés, il y en a pas dans toutes les régions
En France, par exemple, ça concerne les régions du centre et de l'Est mais on en trouve aussi en Suisse,
en Autriche, en Allemagne et au Pays-Bas. Le problème c'est que si vous tenez absolument à manger des fruits
des bois, c'est que, ni le lavage ni la congélation ne tuent les œufs. Il y a que la cuisson qui est efficace.
Alors, si vous n'aimez pas les confitures, cueillez vos baies en hauteur, c'est-à-dire à un endroit où même
un renard très vénère et très agile ne peut pas déféquer. Et quand c'est trop tard, on fait quoi ?
Bon, comme on l'a vu quand on s'en rend compte, en général, les larves sont déjà bien installées. Dans ces cas-là, il y a
deux solutions : l'opération, qui consiste à retirer les parties infectées voire infestées par le parasite, avec
parfois l'obligation d'avoir recours à une greffe d'organes, de foie, notamment. Il y a aussi des
traitements sous forme de médicaments qui ne font que ralentir le développement des bestioles sans les tuer.
Donc, c'est, à vie. J'ai chié l'ambiance, nan ? De toute façon, je m'en fou, je n'aime pas ça, les mûres.
Voilà, "DTC spécialité" c'est fini, on se retrouve à la rentrée pour une nouvelle vidéo. D'ici là, vous
connaissez la chanson, mettez vous bien et puis surtout, portez vous bien.
* Musique de fin *